okay good morning everybody how are we
all are we all
good yes good good good okay number four
it becomes bad I love to get a selfie
with you all and I do like you all to
wave okay you have to you don't have to
but I would really appreciate if you
waved and I'm going to try and get you
all in so we're going to do that now
before you're all like oh my God I'm out
of here okay so this is just like you
came it's fine all right so I'm G to see
if I can get all of you in that's oh it
helps if I turn the camera around
doesn't it lovely black screen okay all
right all right all right we've got all
everywhere I'm going to do it at an
angle so I'm going to count you
in good good all right three two
one yay all right I need a bit more of
you lot over over here this slot are you
ready three two
one okay all right yay we're friends now
all righty
so my name's ilila and this is asp.net
basics for experts so you're all experts
now because you're here um and I'll tell
you a little bit about why I did this
talk in a moment but I am a developer
Advocate at VMware yes VMware does do a
little bit of not not net uh net teeny
weeny little tiny weeny bit and I'm I'm
in it so um I'm also five times MVP a
GitHub star a progress ninja and I
founded the women of.net initiative so
if you want to know anything about that
you can find me around and have a chat
and I used to sit on the net Foundation
as well now there are no slides in this
talk everything is on my GitHub and I am
Leila hyen p on GitHub and everywhere
else everywhere else I'm Lea codes it
okay just to confuse you um but we all
create our GitHub first don't we well
before anything else uh so you can find
me I'm I'm building up a lot of YouTube
stuff so you can come and watch my very
crazy YouTube videos but enough of all
of that what are we going to talk about
today well what am I going to talk about
and you're going to listen to so we're
going to look at some of the basic
foundational stuff of your asp.net
applications uh the things that you may
forget the things that you may just
gloss over things that if you've come
from an older version of net that you
may not be so familiar with so things
we're going to look at top level
statements minimal hosting model uh
Global using directives dependency
injection uh minimal apis we're going to
touch on all of this okay okay uh HTTP
clients and client factories a little
bit of resiliency and then we'll see
what else we have time for but I'm
usually packed in by that time uh so why
did I do this talk well uh way back when
net 6 came
out I I did a net new and was
horrified absolutely horrified with what
came up in the template
what is this where's my startup what is
all of this I was just like oh my God I
can't deal so if we go back to Net 5
what we got was a program and our
program looked like that um how is it at
the back the size of that is it okay we
did check earlier but I just want to do
another check good thank you all right
so I will zoom in and out um this is
what we had and let me just be clear you
can still have this all right it's fine
and a lot of You may wish to have this
for various reasons but this is what we
had and then we had this startup file
and I was very attached to my startup
file and this is where I'd register
everything and do all my magic and you
know make my app how I wanted
it and uh
then net 6 came out and I was like oh
what on Earth is this so if I go this
this way it is here I changed it because
my ryer instance crashed we had
something that looked like this now this
one is
populated um but if we go through and
look this is just a program I was like
where is my startup file what is all
this scripty very like
javascrip type looking file I was not
happy so I went through all of these
ways to Donnet new
the old way okay so I would I would do a
net new um web API use Net 5 and then I
would manually go up and update it to
net 6 just to get the template that I
liked like the the startup and
everything and I was really like anti
anti this new fangled way of doing
things I don't know why I'm normally
quite open-minded I've actually got a
video on my whole thought about this
because I felt so strongly about it but
then I started to think about why we
moved over to this model and as I say
you can still have the the other hosting
model as well you this Net 5 I'm going
to flip a lot that way the net 5 version
where you have your startup as well and
you know if you're registering a lot of
Middle where sometimes that may be
preferable but I'm going to be talking
about this minimal one one today no not
that that's the one I wanted to show you
a minute ago let's go over uh so we're
going to be talking about this which is
the minimal hosting pattern and we also
have this uh top level statement so
what's happened why don't we have the
program and the main and everything now
well this is all static now we've got
rid of all that ceremony and I started
to think well actually getting rid of
some ceremony might be quite good I love
bringing new people into the net
ecosystem so making it easier for them
and less ceremony less files actually
seemed like a good thing so I started to
come round to the idea of this and then
um I've done a lot of uh node
development and I've used
expressjs and I thought well actually
this is quite similar I'm actually going
to lose my makono because it's getting
quite toasty in here with all our hot
bodies releasing heat um and I thought
well this is quite familiar so if we've
got people coming over from uh the node
and JavaScript world this is going to be
more familiar for them and I was like
okay I could probably get behind this
and then I really started to get behind
this and started to think how how can I
make this work for me because one of the
things I didn't like was it's all in one
file now everything is dumped into this
file and if you've got big applications
this is going to get quite messy and
you're going to have really big files
and all your dependencies list listed
there all your minimal apis so I started
to look at how do you architect the
application in such a way that it made
sense and was easy to find things so I'm
going to share some of those things with
you today um it's not rocket science
it's just a nice way of doing things and
um you can have a go at doing them in a
similar way or find your own ways but
I'm going to share these with you all
right so uh let's go and explore what a
net 6 or seven and seem to be net 8
application is now um if you are
interested in net 8 stuff I don't like
to be on the bleeding edge I just about
Float On The Cutting Edge so I won't
even play with net 8 until it's in an RC
um I know what's coming and I'll point
out a few things that might be of
interest to you um but you won't see any
net 8 stuff today because I like like to
wait I like to wait till it's settled
otherwise you know that stuff might be
pulled out or
changed excuse me all right so let's
come in and have a look here um we have
this web application Builder and this is
what we're going to um add all of our
middle wear and things like that too so
this is going to replace um what we had
in our startup file so that's going to
replace our configure Services stuff so
we can start playing around now when you
do a net new you're not going to have
this Builder do
configuration um you add that later and
the order in which you add things to
your configuration
matters uh we have the um it's going to
go down in that order so anything that
comes after something before is going to
overwrite it and I'm going to show you
that in a moment uh so this is why we
can have our Json file our local
development stuff first
and then we can have our environment
variables and then our user Secrets if
you're using them in development and
then your command line arguments so it's
going too in that order now we can bring
in any type of file to this as if you're
using external configuration maybe
you've got lots of instances or you want
to share your configuration across some
files uh you can you can do that here
you can add that in so what I'm going to
do first is just show you that the order
matters and how that comes out so I have
I'm just going to grab a value from our
configuration um and there's lots of
ways that you can use the options
pattern if you've heard of the options
pattern um it came out in 2018 I want to
say no it came out before that it came
out with net one when it came out so the
options pattern is a really nice way of
managing your
configuration um and if you want to know
more about that I have a video all on
that uh but basically you can bind your
configuration to it and add it to your
ioc your inversion of control container
and inject it anywhere and there's lots
of things that you can do with it um
there's different interfaces to use
whether you want it as a single turn if
you want it um updatable if you're live
updating your configuration so um you
can bind all of your configuration to
that object as well but let's just start
by putting a break point in here um I'm
going
to just uncomment this one oops let's go
and have a look so what we expect now um
are if I go show you what that external
one is it's external
value come back I want to be over here
external and then in my app
settings we can come down
here and you'll see I've just got app
settings there all right um so when we
come to here if I F10 over
that we should see it's app settings if
you can't see that so that's coming from
my app settings and then if we stop
that and I just swap those
around and this you know it seems really
obvious but these are the types of
things that you can't always see when
you're developing you'll be like oh my
goodness why am I not getting that and
it's about order and we're going to look
at some other things that depend on
order also so if we come over and I
hover over that you can see we've got
external so definitely the order matters
and that's a way that you can I've just
shown you how to use external
configuration now and if you were to
bind that in the options
pattern so if we
did
Builder do
services.
add
option and I needed a model there but we
wrapped it like
this um just as a bit of a pseudo code
we could bring that in and bind that
external value to a strongly typed uh
model um and then we could also do some
validation on it we could do um to make
sure is it a string or should it be an
integer and things like that so we get
um a lot of niceties coming through when
we use the options pattern um and why
have I got that there we go I am a bit
handicapped I've got a sore thumb so my
typing is going to be a little bit extra
um and that should be uh builder.
configuration there builder.
configuration dog valy you get the idea
okay and then we can start to inject
that now if you were doing
um like updating your configuration live
you would use uh I options monitor or ey
options snapshot um so you may not know
about those you may have just seen like
eye options of type whatever your type
is and injecting that into uh your
Constructor or into your service of
whatever but if you then go and use eye
options um monitor that's going to be um
updated and that's a good one to use
because it's a singlet ton so you can
put it into any life cycle if you use IE
options snapshot that's going to be
scoped so you can't inject that into a
Singleton so just make sure you're using
the correct one um but that's going to
give you live updating to your
configuration if you're using external
configuration so that's a quick look at
that oh that was really loud I
apologize wow I should have had a glass
and then you could have heard me
slurping that rather
than but
anyway okay so let me just uh minimize
this bottom screen here and let's get
this out of the way and we're going to
start having a little bit more of an
explore all right so we've got things
like our control rollers and um I've got
Swagger in here so I can show you stuff
so that's what this is the end points
Explorer and and Swagger and then down
here we're just saying if they're in
development we're going to use those so
they won't be available if this was in
production and then a few other things
down here um and then we come down to
the minimal apis now this is what really
looks like Express JS and you can use
them in conjunction with controllers you
see I've got controllers mapped here so
you can do both you can do either or um
it's very flexible you've got to think
about the reasons why you might want to
controller over an AP a minimal API um
there are whole talks on minimal apis
but it really just depends on um like if
you were injecting a lot of things you
were going to use a lot of services um
in your your API endpoints um and you're
going to repeat that it may be better to
do those all in a controller and then
you can inject them all into your
Constructor and do it all like that um
it really depends but let's have a
little quick look down
here now there's a lot of things I don't
like about this particular
implementation of the API um and it
comes with this stuff here so we're
going to rectify that um and because
we're going to add all of that to our uh
dependency injection ioc container okay
so just a quick look this is a a get
endo this is the what's called pattern
you can see ryers telling me what that
is uh so this will be on the endpoint
get waffle toppings all of my demos are
always food related I love food uh so
there we go and then what we else what
else we have in here is an expression so
I have this async expression
here and then I can go in do whatever I
need to do now at the moment I'm
creating an HTTP client I'm not
disposing of it
um it's not looking very good so um boo
hiss at that way I've done my HTTP
client here um this is a very wrong way
to use an HTTP
client now you may be going oh why why
is that well um HTTP client is a wrapper
for HTTP message Handler um and it's
actually designed just to be used once
okay uh to be instantiated once rather
so in this one that's going to be
instantiated and not disposed every time
this mpoint is called which is terrible
that could lead to socket exhaustion and
all sorts of horrific stuff so even if
you wrap that in a using it will dispose
of the object but the connection might
not be severed immediately okay your
your websocket connection so you can
then if you had a high volume come to
socket exhaustion so I'm going to show
you in a minute what we can do to make
that better
um there's quite a few things that we
can do all right so what do I actually
need in here well I need this waffle
creation service and just because this
is a minimal API doesn't mean I can't
use uh dependency injection so I'm going
to say from Services I've got this
little um annotation here and then I'm
going to say I would really like an
instance of waffle creation service
injected I've not done this have I no
what was
that wowers okay that was like your code
has
failed uh that's still to come it's
inevitable so we have our waffle
creation service WCS so we've now got
that available so I'm actually just
going to get rid of all of this okay um
so that's looking better we're going to
inject that instead and then we'll
manage the those dependencies elsewhere
okay so um that now is kind of more
normal but if I ran this now it's going
to be wait wait we don't have a waful
creation service to give this API so
let's go and fix that first um now you
can get this code as I said on here so I
put lots of notes in here and we're
going to start adding our dependencies
so what we need first is Builder
doservices because we're adding it to
our I service collection and then we we
have our different life cycles um I've
got a demo for life cycles which I'll
show you if we have time so I'm actually
going to say add Singleton we have
Singleton transient and scoped um and uh
Singleton will be there created once uh
scoped will be created for the life
cycle of our request and then transient
is every time it's asked for okay and I
can demo that for you as well if we have
time all right so this was the
waffle creations service wasn't it that
we had is it going to ask me for some
stuff no there we go okay but that also
had a dependency on the ingredient
serice so let's go and add that Builder
doservices
do
add and then we can have waffle
ingredients
service yes okay um now this one was
also had an interface implementation so
we can go I waffle creation service and
we can implement this waffle creation
service like
so and then I would need to come down
here and uh change this one to be rather
than that I'd need to request an
instance or an implementation of eyle
creation so we can use our interfaces
like so just the same as you would in
anything else that you've got your uh
dependency injection um and a note here
if you add multiple implementations it's
going to take the last one as your
default okay so if I added another one
after here I have another waffle
creation service then that would be the
one that would be passed to our minimal
API unless I asked for an i innumerable
a collection of I waffle creation
service and then would be like here here
have them all okay so that gives you a
lot of flexibility if you're using
strategy pattern or something like that
um you could have all your different
strategies there and then get them as an
i inumerable
I'm going to cough now
okay okay um and Waffle ingredient
service has an dependency on that that
pesky HTTP client so what we're going to
do is go builder. services. add HTTP
client yay and I'm just going to do that
one just the generic one now what that's
doing is going to use uh the HTTP client
Factory okay it will manage the lifetime
of your clients okay it will dispose of
them it will reuse them and now you
don't have to worry about them you're
not going to get the socket exhaustion
everything will just be taken care of so
do that don't do um usings and all of
this and dispose don't handle it
yourself unless for some reason you have
to just just use that the HTTP client
Factory and I'll show you some other
things that you can do with that also
all right so now we've got our
dependencies I'm pretty sure that this
should just work
should Famous Last Words let's just go
and check we ignore all the errors and
the not the errors the warnings they
don't mean
anything we don't we're not worried
about warnings what why can't that be
why is this not reachable it was
reachable earlier I tested it you see
this is it that noise was a precursor
what are you telling me in here wait
wait wait break point yay thank you
oh my goodness okay now I have to press
the right button to continue There we
go eagle eyes in the audience Harrah I
love it when you're pair programming
with me Harrah there we go okay so let's
see if my di worked we're going to try
it out
execute yes it has we've gone to our
ingredient service and we've got some
nice waffle ingredients don't worry
about The Binding on that it's horrible
it's immaterial okay so we can see that
we've successfully got our di
working but remember how I said when you
start adding loads of things to your
program file it's going to get unwieldy
so let's address that next I want to get
all of these dependencies out of here
and we're going to write an extension
method to do that so this remember I
said I started to look at patterns we
could use to make this more manageable
and more enjoyable to use so if we come
over
here I've got some files ready and I've
got this fantastically named ad
dependencies I suggest you uh use
whatever naming convention suits you and
you can group them but this is it for
now now you may notice I have a partial
here you may be deeply opposed to
partial that's okay you don't have to
have a partial service collection
extension that's my methodology okay I I
like to name my file the name of the
extension method and then I like to put
them all in a partial class of service
collection extensions that's my
preference you can name this whatever
you want and not have it as a partial as
long as it's static okay so let's go and
add that extension method so we're going
to have a public static now this needs
to be an i service collection thank you
intellisense um and this one is going to
be our ad dependencies
okay and then no not square brackets no
why did you give me square
brackets all right so we've got that and
now in here we need to
um put a keyword and my brain has gone
blank this thank you oh my goodness I
don't know if it's the heat in here and
I'm like there's a keyword that I need
to use and it's this thank you okay so
this uh we have our service collection
services and then we're going to go and
return Services okay so now we've got
our extension method
ready we can come over to our program
and what I'm going to do is just get rid
of that uh and I'm going to paste that
there okay so now we've got that but
it's empty so let's go and sort that out
uh we've got that and we're going to
come over here and we can just paste
those and just sort those
out and then we can add our HTTP
client okay so let's go um so we've
already instantly tidied that up and you
can start um encapsulating this more
okay you could have this top level ad
dependencies and then below here you
could have a whole load of private
methods where you add things in
different named spacer in different
named methods and then you could add all
of those methods in here and then you're
keeping it nice and tidy so that you can
keep building on this architecture and
learning what works for you okay now um
we can also do that for like databases
I've got that in a separate one here so
I've got my DB context oh go go away um
and you can see I'm passing in my um I'm
using SQL Server so I've passed that in
and you'll notice here that I can also
pass other information through to these
extension methods so in this case I'm
going to need that configuration so you
can start adding that and then if we go
look at our
program you can see I just passed that
Builder do configuration through so you
can start writing lots of your own
extension methods here um and
encapsulating all of your code and
keeping this really readable so if I go
through and read this and go oh that's
adding my dependencies that's adding my
databases so it makes it really readable
and
maintainable really paranoid about that
now okay so um that's that instantly
sold this to me that oh I can go and
tidy it up with extension
methods okay so let's go and have a
closer look look at what else we can do
with our um HTTP client actually no
we're going to have a look at this one
first because I think there's some
important things just to cover with life
cycles still and adding
dependencies now um the idea behind this
and this was because all of my teammates
are Java spring developers every single
one of them not w does.net
um and I had to present co-present with
a spring Advocate and he I I was doing
half. net and he was doing Java and we
were swapping between it for this
presentation and he was like well how do
you add like private dependencies and I
was like
um um I I don't know so we started to
think about this and I he sort of tried
to explain to me why he had these and
but the idea is that if you add
something to your ioc container it's
sort of globally available and I'd love
to know how you all deal with that as
well if there's something that you don't
want everything to have access to um so
this was my
workaround oh um so I have this
marketing private dependency I don't
want to add that to the ioc container I
just want that only available here uh so
you could say well why am I injecting it
but let's just say I I am all right
let's assume I need to okay so I have my
marketing private dependency and my
marketing mpoint service has a uh
dependency on that okay and my marketing
endpoints service needs to be available
to the entire um application okay uh so
I go and create
this um and then I add the dependency
and then I add that in here now there's
something really really wrong about this
imagine marketing endpoints sounds like
it's going to need a dependency on an
HTTP client perhaps yeah so at the
moment the way I've added this just by
adding the already instantiated object
my ioc container has no awareness of the
life cycle of my marketing endpoints
object okay it won't dispose of it it
won't do anything for me so in this
instance I would manually have to go and
um manage that life cycle okay um so
this is where you could run into trouble
so I'll show you how to fix it but I do
just have to call out my good friend
Steve Collins he's got a fantastic blog
series on this so stev talks code.
c. um he's an amazing individual um and
he's written an amazing blog series so I
highly recommend reading it so but I
will show you how we can fix
it um so rather than having it like so
what we're going to do is we're going to
call it in the context like this so now
we're we're adding it and we're going to
create it within the context of our
service provider so it will then know
how to do it so we're just going to go
new marketing end points and we're going
to pass in PMD okay so just by Chang
changing the code to be that way our ioc
is now managing that life cycle for us
okay so we don't have to worry about it
it will call dispose for us when
necessary and again it's all sorted for
you so just using these little things
just to make your application more
resilient and better is really helpful
okay so that was that one um and now
let's go and look a little bit closer at
h PTP client
Factory go I'm zipping through this
today it's cuz you're all pair
programming with me isn't it it's like
oh okay so I think we are actually going
to have time for our life cycle so let's
let's have a quick look at that now just
so I want to make sure that everybody
understands um the scope transient and
uh Singleton life cycles okay and it's
nothing like seeing it in action uh so
down here I have builder. services.
addlife cycles and if we go look at not
that one this
one um pretty straightforward it goes
and
creates um three random numbers and adds
it to a list and then returns that list
okay and what I then have in
um the place where I add it in add life
cycles we're going to have a look at
each one so the first one we're going to
add as a Singleton so I want you just to
have a think about what you're going to
expect to see when I call this minimal
API down here so you can see I've got
two requests for life cycles uh so I'm
going to then just print them to screen
okay so we're going to ask for that list
from each
injectable here okay so let's go and run
that okay what do you think you're going
to see with our list of three random
numbers the same was
that I think you'll be right so you can
see
054 if I request it again 054 I can keep
requesting it all day long and it will
just give me the same on both sides okay
yeah and we'll go this way and I'm gonna
stop that again and we're going to no
where is it add life cycles all right so
now let's have a look at
scoped run it
again
okay what do you think you're going to
see on this
one different okay what else have we got
a different over here what have we got
any other
answers same same every time same both
lists okay all right so same both lists
let's do it again so we've got one 3
two there we go 069 so you can see that
was scoped it creates that instance for
the whole of the request here's our
request we ask for an instance twice we
get the same instance okay so now if we
just do the last one I think this one
you're all going to get now aren't you
you can see where this is going let's
stop rerun
it
okay there's no prizes for guessing this
one though okay let's see so what do we
think different every time both lists
different yeah good all right so there
you can see both lists different
different every time so every time we
ask for an instance we're going to get a
new
instance
whoa that was that was quite the unveil
wasn't
it I couldn't have planned that if I
tried
the demo gods are with me today woohoo
all
righty so uh let's uh move on so
hopefully you know that's your
understanding of it but we've just
reconfirmed that I think it's always
nice just to see it properly in action
to go yes that's how I thought it worked
okay um so let's go and close these off
all right so let's go and go back to our
dependencies file here we can do better
okay so we have our I waffle creation
service um that has the dependency on
waffle ingredients service um let's have
a quick look at the Waffle ingredient
service okay so we can see that has a
dependency on HTTP client fine fair
enough we're making an external HTTP
Call to um
this
function
here so let's go and make these better
so I'm actually going to take them out
of my dependencies and we're going to
look in this client and policies all
right I'm just going to drop them in
here for
now so we have this generic add HTTP
client here okay um and so you can see
we have that but there other things that
we can do with our HTTP client Factory
we can have named and we can have
strongly typed so let's go and see what
that would look like so if we wanted a
strongly typed one Services I have this
big block about typing services in code
so we're going to add an HTTP
client and this time I'm going to give
it a name let go
NDC and then in here here we can have an
expression that was a really bad
expression there we go okay and we can
have that on the end is that not no it's
not an oh yes we don't want that we want
client okay there we go um so now we've
got our client we can start doing all
the things that you might do in your
Constructor so when you inject your HTTP
client what what kind of thing might you
do uh client
uh Base address equals new
URI um and then I don't go know
HTP something you
know okay we can have that um that
semicolon uh we can go and put in
headers we can do whatever we need okay
and the beauty of this is that we're
setting it up once and then when I want
to go and use that
what did I just do oh my God I can see
flickering are we still there okay
hopefully we're there all right so when
I want to go and use that I can inject
my HTTP client and get a HTTP client
Factory and then go and um get that
named instance in my controller okay um
so you can start doing that and then you
can reuse that rather than having all of
that code in your Constructor now same
say you wanted to change that basee URI
okay That Base address for this
particular HTTP client NDC has changed
it's not not in Copenhagen anymore it's
now in Porto so we're going to change
that Base address if I had um created
all of those base addresses in all of my
controller instances I'd have to go and
fight through all of those here it's
centralized it's just update in one
place which is you know really really
useful okay um there are some other uses
of this as well is this going to tell me
if I go okay so there's a big difference
between these two okay if I hover over
this one do you see that this is I
service collection okay and if I come
down to this
one it's extending I
HTTP client Builder Okay that that gives
us a whole host of new options which
we're going to explore in a minute so
there's another reason for having named
or strongly typed um just to show you
what a strongly typed one looks like
let's do
this Tada strongly tighted okay just
done like that so this now is the named
because you see we've just given it a
stringy name and now this is a strongly
typed HTTP client um and the beauty of
that is now we have these additional um
methods that we can add
policies uh to our application with okay
so I've got some lined up here now um I
like to use poly I recommend that you
use poly uh you can use poly straight up
for any any problematic method call in
your application okay we're only going
to look at HTTP here
guess what I have a video on uh Polly
that you can go and watch that will show
you how to put it on any method uh so
things that you might want to put uh
policies around are going to be things
like uh database calls anything where
you might have a failure anything where
you're calling outside your application
or if you've got some really flaky code
and you're like this is really
problematic you can start wrapping it in
policies and this is instantly going to
make your application more resilient so
if we come here here let's go and have a
look at um poly project I'm just going
to shove net in
there the poly project now I'm going to
go to the GitHub one because they have
this
amazing um chart down here it is here
isn't it is it here yes okay I I'm going
to make that bigger um I love this chart
and the reason why I love this chart is
this AKA document WR writers put aka in
your documents okay it's so great so we
can see that retry oh maybe it's just a
blip doesn't that cement it in your head
a little bit more um circuit breaker
stop doing if it hurts okay and give the
system a break we're going to look at a
circuit breaker I'm going to explain
that in more detail uh so the poly
project as say you can use it on its own
or we have an extension Library a new
get package um from Microsoft I think it
actually comes in with net um but you
can use and it's extending that IH HTTP
client Builder so it means that we can
start tacking it on and it wraps it
nicely F so that's what we're going to
have a quick look
at but let me just go and explain um
what a circuit breaker is okay I'm going
to get up my nice
picture all right so let's say we have
service a talking to service B I'm going
to do it the other way around so it's
right for you service a talking to
service B so service a is sending
requests across to service a uh B this
is b b right and a just keeps sending
those requests over and B is going oh
hang on a minute whoa whoa I can't cope
and it it's starting to get overloaded
and it's just like no I can't deal with
this no I'm out of here okay what
happens then service a keeps sending it
it's not getting a response everything's
falling apart okay if we put a circuit
breaker
in we have it it comes from the
electrical circuits so it's that same
principle a closed circuit is good all
right we're closed we've closed the loop
we've got those request response going
across to service B now when service B
is having its little wobbly we're going
to pop open the circuit breaker okay so
now the circuit is open and we have
something called the failure threshold
okay you can set that so let's just say
that was three if it got three dud
responses from that or no responses
whatever you set it up to listen for
we're going to open that circuit and
then you can set a time delay let's just
say we're going to wait 10 seconds to
see if service b gets its act together
and then what we do is half open you
don't want to just kick up because
service B may not be on its feet again
so you send one request that's called
the half open state
okay so you send one across if that is
successful we close the circuit continue
as normal if it isn't successful that is
grinding it's the dreaded earrings I was
warned about
this okay oh my
God one second let
just
I can't take them all out I don't know
why it's
moved okay I flung one over here I'm
just going to keep my head really still
okay so where was I we've got that
closed and everything's passing through
okay so let's go and have a look at how
we can put that into action actually I'm
going to show you this really terrifying
diagram
now remember I said earlier that
configuration needed to be in a certain
order guess what policies do too okay
isn't that the most
Divine diagram you've ever seen yeah
okay this tells you how um your request
goes through all the policy middleware
okay so let's just zoom in a little bit
on here so it's really important if you
think about this as um
each one is wrapped in an um like a TR
catch this is going to be your TR catch
thing okay but we've got extension
methods that can handle that for us so
we have our calling code it's going to
go through falling fallback this is all
the different things that policy has so
let's just say it's going to go fullback
wait and retry and then circuit breaker
and then execute a delegate that's the
way we're looking at it because we're
not going to look at the other things
okay and then it comes right back up
through it so you have to get these in
the right order so just wanted to put
that there um okay so where's my code
it's back this way let going to take a
look uh so you can see we've got these
things in here so uh this one and this
one we can add these policies too not
the Gen the generic um HTTP client I
know it's not a generic but you I mean
generic in the non-coding sense okay um
so let's go and have a look I've written
some of these before because no one
needs to see me painfully write these
out and if we all right I haven't got a
fall back in here uh the retry is keep
trying okay however many times I State
go and try again um fullback would be
everything has failed do this instead so
that's why we saw it at the the very
start or very end of our
request so our request our retry policy
is going to be if I get my HTTP response
message and on that message um I do not
have a success status code or I don't
have um or I have the result not found
okay wait and retry so we're going to
try it three times and then the time
time is going to be each time it's just
going to wait a little bit longer so
it's going to be 10 time 10 seconds 20
seconds 40 seconds so on and so forth
okay so you can Define all of this and
there's a few other things that you can
do but this is a basic
implementation so that's the first thing
that's going to happen when we get a
failure okay it's going to wait and
retry three times now if it fails three
times we're going to hit our circuit
breaker because that is wrapping our
retry policy okay
and this one here is going to handle a
result status code that's flickering
again isn't it um internal server error
so we're going to have a 500 there it's
going to do three things that's our
threshold uh failure threshold handled
events allowed before breaking is three
and then we're going to have a from
minutes let's just whack that down a
little bit we're not going to hang
around from and let's
have let's have 10
seconds okay and then I've got some um
little uh methods down here just to
print some stuff so you could have this
writing to your logs this is a perfect
place to write your logs I've just got
it going to a console. right line
because you know it's a demo but this is
where you could start to handle those um
and get oh hang on there's a problem
going on and start logging it dealing
with it okay so how how do we add
these well I um I commented this one out
now we have this nice wrap thing let's
do that
first control casy all right so we can
wrap it you can see I've got policy wrap
async and you can see I put them in um
and it's going to wrap them for me all
right and
then we can add them to our policy
Handler Allin one go okay and now you
can see we've added that to our strongly
typed
HTTP client right that's ready to use um
what I am going to do is well actually
let's just go with it um I have
builtin peskiness in this API so you can
see
here on a random occasion uh this is
going to throw a 500
okay as its status codee so that's
what's going to happen um and then I can
actually if I remember how to be
clever with this I can bring yes like
like that so we
should here's our API and then if we
come over here I'm going to make sure
that I've added this to the program ha
none of you caught that did
you I'm sure you would have told me once
it all failed and it wasn't working so
let's go and add this to our
[Music]
program so we've got have I already
written it no so we're going to add
Builder do
Services dot add clients and policies so
now it's available otherwise we would
have gone I don't have that what are you
talking about um and let's go ahead and
run
all right so you can see here I'm going
to
just can I squid that along a little bit
yes okay so let's go and try
this we're expecting to see some
failures okay well that was straight
away a good one error okay so now you
can see it's waiting and it retried okay
so you can see it retried once and it
went through let's have another go okay
it's good it's gonna be all good isn't
it be pesky random numbers don't fail
me we've got an error so you can see oh
my goodness come on give me several
errors in a row Okay so we've got
two come on see it's waiting longer now
it's going to wait even
longer yes
all right so
now you can see we hit circuit breaker
broken circuit exception okay our
circuit has opened all right now if I
time
that I didn't do it quick enough okay it
was I would have got 10 no maybe I did
okay if I wait 10 seconds it will allow
me to do that right now if that circuit
is open it's not even going to let me
try Okay it's it's just going to say hey
hey I'm open not doing anything and now
if we go over here I
think we should have had some messages
printed somewhere I would have thought
they be in
here maybe
not I don't use Rider enough because I
work on a PC at home um maybe no I never
can remember where oh here it is okay
was that in here
I would expect to have seen somewhere
those uh things that I put in here the
uh circuit breaker is open um but
however that should be running
again all is good you see now the
circuit closed everything's running
again so this can really start to manage
potential issues in your code without
them bubbling up to your end user so
they're not going to get like a a flop
of an application
you can be like oh I know that there's a
potential problem with this particular
service I'm going to handle it so
therefore everything is more resilient
you let you put in these code bits in
place to manage potential issues so that
your end user isn't even aware of it
okay so that's key to resilient
apps and we have all of those tools more
or less in our basic web application
here
sorry losing my voice now okay so we can
see that we can have that and we can
start to do different policies per um
HTTP client we can start really
itemizing this um and you can really get
control over how you handle these known
potential issues obviously the unknown
you can't always write a Handler for
that or or deal with that they are the
exceptional exceptions um but if you
know that well this API I'm calling is
outside of my control um maybe their
servers will go down maybe they get
hacked it's outside your control you
need to put those resilient um methods
into your code to handle that potential
issue okay um so you can do that
pretty pretty easily without having to
go and and do too much there's some
great articles out there I as say I have
a video on it um that covers
it um and just by adding a few little
things to your code you can instantly
make it um more
resilient okay um so if we come back the
last thing I want to show you
is we don't just write extension methods
for our dependencies we can start to
write extension methods to shove all of
our
um a minimal apis in okay so we can
actually extend the web application you
can see this is our app and I've done
that somewhere add apis okay so you can
see here I've got um web application
extens iions this one isn't partial
because it's the only place I do it and
you can start to group all of your uh
minimal apis into logical collections
okay so maybe you have all of a certain
type so maybe they're all um I don't
know your ordering ones can all go in
one extension and all your admin ones
can go in another extension so you can
still group them and you're not going
down the way of having your heavyweight
controller so let's just go and grab
this little bit down here try and keep
my head still it's only because the tech
told me my earrings were going to bang
on this mic and I've never had this
problem before so it jinxed
me okay so now we can stick that in here
no we can't because I haven't written it
yet so we can
go public
static um and then we need a web
application
okay and this one's going to be add
apis and then I remember the word now
thank you this web
application and then we're going to go
app and then down here and then now I
can drop those in okay and why are you
unhappy down here what's your
problem what have I
done thank you
return wait wait
what oh thank you thank you return I was
thinking that return I'm like what's
going on with
the return app the basics huh okay so
we've got that and then um with our
minimal apis we've got a lot of
different things we've got app dot
map uh put and we can go and do that and
the last quick thing is just say you
know let's just give that name whatever
it is um and then our
expression you know we had the body uh
from Services up here well this is going
to be sorry not put let's make that a
post um I'm going to post something from
this so we can go uh we can tell it that
we can have a from body and let's just
call that
order okay um and then we can give that
order so we can pass that in um is that
in here yes okay but we can also say
have our services in there so we can
still add our
services and drop that in so we can
still do all of our dependency injection
and still get something from our post
the body so this post will then expect a
body and then we can go and do whatever
we want with that body okay um so we are
at time that was a pretty well- wind
whip round of all the things I wanted to
show you um and the only thing I missed
was Global usings which came inet 6 um
so you can add any C file name whatever
you want to call it Global usings is
generally what I like to call it uh
let's just go class I'll just call it gu
uh we collect all of no go away uh
Delete all of
that and then just to make something
Global you go Global and then we can go
and grab something from
program something that we'll use a lot
let's just say system. Json we'll
probably use that a lot so I can take
that
out and we can drop that in there done
now that's available globally we don't
need to put it in there and that's it
thank you very much and I appreciate
your
time and oh I'm off um I didn't see very
many green next to huge stacks of yellow
and red so if you run out of greens I
don't know I don't know you there's a
lot of you in here thank you for coming
but yeah there wasn't enough greens
compared to yellows and reds so don't
just like pick whatever's left over okay
and if you have questions I'm going to
be around you can come and find me but
thank you very
much